what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data my name
is richard and this is the channel where
we talk about all things data and we're
weighing in today on the biggest rivalry
of data science this is the Ford versus
GM the Coke versus Pepsi the Marvel vs.
DC I'm talking of course about our vs.
Python this debate has been going on for
several years and I don't see it calming
down anytime in the near future and I'm
mainly looking at those of you out there
who are maybe in school right now you
have a statistics or mathematics focus
maybe some of you also who are in the
computer science realms maybe you know
some programming languages like Java C
C++ etc but not necessarily Python some
of you out there in the data management
space who knows sequel you want to move
over to the data science world but
you're really thinking do I want to
learn R or do I want to learn Python my
thirty second answer to that question
and it's kind of a lawyer answer which a
lot of you might not like but it depends
it depends on you as an individual how
you're wired and what exactly in the
data science world you're actually
interested in but what I would say is
you really can't go wrong with either of
them what you want to do is learn one
and get good at it you don't want to get
analysis paralysis where you're weighing
the options between the two and then you
never learn either no if you get good at
one of them you're gonna be in an
amazing position so I'm gonna do a
detailed comparison between these two
and specifically we're gonna look at
which one of the two are easier to pick
up what are the capabilities of each of
them and then as we move into 2020 we're
gonna do some popularity comparisons so
what does it look like people in the
community you're using and then also
what does it look like data science jobs
are looking for in 2020 before I do all
that smash the like button also hit the
subscribe button and tap the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whatever I up
a new video for those of you who are
totally unfamiliar with one of these
languages or the other it is a little
helpful to know a little bit of the
history and the backstory of them so
starting with our our was made available
to the public in the year 2000 and it
was made open-source just a little bit
after that it was created by
statisticians and the idea behind it was
to make data analysis easier and first
the objective was to make it easier for
statisticians and then the population at
large so it's important to keep in mind
with our it was created looking at
programming and data analysis in general
through the perspective of statisticians
now as for Python Python was released in
1991 and it was developed by the sky'
guido van rossum the idea behind it was
to communicate complex concepts with
fewer lines of code with the idea being
that this would enhance developer and
programmer productivity and a massive
emphasis behind it was on readability so
python quickly became open-source
software and once it did people began to
develop packages like numpy and pandas
and these packages are really the
foundation for data analysis and data
science in python as it stands today and
so I'm telling you all this to
illustrate a pretty important
distinction R was created by
statisticians for other statisticians to
do statistical analysis Python was
created as a general-purpose programming
language now that you have some
background on the two languages you
probably want to know which one is
easier to learn and this one depends a
lot on your background but the
overwhelming majority of people do seem
to think Python is easier to pick up
than R however that actually wasn't the
case for me my background was in
statistics and I was familiar with the
mathematical concepts of like
statistical tests and models long before
I was familiar with any programming
languages so I started playing around
with R
and I saw how easy it was to spin up the
LM function or maybe to run statistical
tests without even having to worry about
packages and it was super easy for me to
pick up expand my knowledge base and get
reasonably good at having said that
that's because I'm wired as a
statistician so the ability using R to
quickly prototype different models that
really appeal to me now if that's not
you you don't have a statistics
background or your wire as a programmer
and as a coder yourself Python will
honestly probably be easier to pick up
for you than R is next let's go over the
capabilities of these two languages now
we have to start off by saying that for
the purposes of data analysis and data
science R and Python are completely
competent languages for the overwhelming
majority of things that you could want
to do both languages are going to be
able to support your needs but having
said that there are certain things which
one language is generally thought to be
a little better than the other at in my
opinion and I think this is a pretty
commonly held conception our Blose
Python out of the water as far as data
visualization is concerned so R has the
very popular ggplot2 package and this is
just an incredibly powerful very
flexible language and it makes use of
the grammar of graphics framework which
is just generally quite intuitive and
for most people it's pretty easy to pick
up
now obviously Python has some
visualization packages Seabourn is one
of the most popular ones and these
packages aren't bad they will work they
will get the job done but R has packages
like ggplot2 gg this HTML widgets
they've been around for a long time
their absolute beasts at creating
beautiful data visualizations and to me
when you compare the package stack from
one to the other Python really can't
compete with ours visualization
capabilities we also have to point out
with our that it was built for
statistical modeling and statistical
tests so for creating those in our it's
sooo
for a quick and easy to do in Python
it's obviously doable you have the stats
models package which is pretty nice for
it
but you really can't compete with how
quick and easy it is to do these things
using are from a design and usability
standpoint almost all our users use the
IDE that is integrated development
environment called our studio with
Python users
there's nowhere near that level of
uniformity there are some who use
pycharm
some use Spyder some use Jupiter there
are tons of different things people use
out there honestly I do think that can
create a bit of a learning curve for
Python for beginners and to this day I
don't like any of those Python IDE s as
much as I like our studio our studio is
really clean it's really easy to use
it's really good at keeping all your
stuff organized and it just makes the
whole programming experience really fun
additionally R has one of my all-time
favorite packages and that's shiny so
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
shiny it's a tool for creating
interactive visualizations and
applications now Python does have some
equivalents like Dash and bouquet but
right now shiny just has incredible
flexibility and it has the power to
handle some amazingly complex
requirements and right now I just don't
think any of the Python modules are
quite on that level yet and likewise our
has what's called our markdown which is
a framework for writing code and quickly
knitting that code and whatever output
and comments that you have into a report
now you can do essentially the same
thing using the jupiter notebook
framework for python but really to me
just the ability to create a report for
virtually any audience without having to
leave your workflow and your coding
environment your ability to do that in r
is just unparalleled now let's move over
to python now as I mentioned python is a
general-purpose programming language and
that's going to be a beneficial factor
in quite a number of ways first and
foremost
Python is going to be faster than our
most of the time now you could be
proactive with R and write code in a
good style in ways that are going to
perform at a reasonable speed but for
more complex pieces of code or for
things like loops which take a longer
amount of time Python is almost always
going to outperform R for that reason
and for others namely the fact it was
designed to do this Python is going to
be better at deploying things into a
production environment now that's not to
say you can't do that or it's impossible
with R but if that's something that's an
objective for you or needs to be on your
radar Python is going to be your tool
Python is also generally considered
better at machine learning and deep
learning so Python has the very popular
scikit-learn package for all of your
machine learning needs and this thing is
just incredibly powerful it's fast and
it's really easy to use and create
models using a very small amount of code
now R has some machine learning packages
like carrots which are also pretty
powerful but they haven't really caught
on in quite the way that scikit-learn
has similarly Python has a lot of deep
learning libraries and Python was the
focus as deep learning became more
mainstream just because of its superior
computational power now R has the Charis
package now and it's making some headway
in the deep learning space but honestly
I do think it's really playing catch-up
to Python Python is also going to blow
our out of the water with respect to
things like natural language processing
and web scraping this really boils down
to pythons amazing computational power
and the fact it can handle big datasets
or just big tasks in general very
efficiently it's these kinds of things
which are more general-purpose tasks
which Python was designed to do and it's
a total beast at them so as you can see
this is not a simple clear-cut story and
a lot of the things I just described are
somewhat subjective and they're based on
what the overall community tends to
think on average so your experience
could
very and honestly when we discuss and we
compare the capabilities between the two
languages it might not be as important
of a discussion as you might think at
first because both r and python have
packages where you can incorporate code
from the other language so provided you
have the know-how you're increasingly
able to leverage the best of both worlds
and when you put it that way it's a lot
easier to learn one function or one
package from another language than to
learn the entire language next let's
look at the popularity of these two
languages with an emphasis on what
things are looking like as we head into
2020 now we're gonna look at the tie yo
B index here for those of you who are
unfamiliar with that it basically
measures how popular programming
languages are by looking at how
frequently they're getting queried by
various search engines so here we have
the top 20 languages you'll see python
is at number 3 and r is at number 18
which is actually down from number 12
which it was at this time last year then
if you look down the ratings column you
see python comprises nine point seven
percent of search queries of these
programming languages but are only makes
a point eight percent now a few things
to keep in mind the tayo b index is not
exactly a scientific methodology and
this also isn't a totally apples to
apples comparison because python is a
general-purpose programming language
while r is generally statistics and data
science specific so that makes it easy
to imagine why it's much higher up on
the list but having said that it's
definitely alarming that r's percentage
of these queries has gone down in the
last year considering data science in
general has not exactly gotten less
popular over the same time period in
fact if we look at R and pythons
popularity over time specifically in the
last two years these things get pretty
interesting here's the tayo B index over
time for R and on the y-axis we have the
rating or just the percentage share of
search results out of all languages
measured by the TOB index that are
happens to get now based on this index
you see that it has doubled in its
rating overall since 2014 but it also
hit a peak around 2018 and it has gone
down quite a bit since then
now we look over here at Python so
python has also skyrocketed in its
popularity since 2014 so again the same
time period but its pattern of
skyrocketing has continued more in fact
it's got even more extreme since 2018
there are also a few metrics that point
to the idea that the catalyst that
fueled pythons enormous growth over this
time period has been data science if you
look at keywords like pandas or data
science and Python just things like that
the rate that which people have been
querying these things using search
engines has increased massively over the
same time period and honestly I don't
have a really good definitive answer for
why Python has been experiencing this
huge boom but our hasn't quite so much
my best guess is that in the last few
years big companies have been really
heavily investing into data science and
that by and large their language of
choice has been Python more so than R it
could also be the case data engineers
use Python more so than R and if we want
to have data scientists and data
engineers as integrated and connected as
possible
they're going to be using the same
platform so python more so than r it
could also be that for a greater share
of the data science community it's
important to have solutions which can
then later be deployed into production
and that's going to give a big edge to
python whereas if a bigger share of the
data science world was doing research
you'd see more of an edge towards R so I
don't know these are just some theories
I have leave a comment down below I'd be
really curious what you guys think I
mentioned earlier that Python is
generally viewed as better and it's more
popular than all
with respect to machine learning so
we're going to look at another
popularity metric this is a poll from
Katie nuggets this is a survey from a
sample of about 1,800 programmers
responding by listing what software they
were using for analytics for data
science and for machine learning as you
can see python is the most popular tool
in 2017 fifty-nine percent of these
programmers reported using Python but
that increased to sixty five point eight
percent in 2019 meanwhile in the same
two years while python was going up our
actually went down it went from fifty
six point six percent in 2017 to just
forty six point six percent last year
now again that's a totally
non-scientific poll but I still think
it's evidence that some real trend has
been going on over the last couple years
next let's look at data science specific
jobs so this is more work from the
awesome people over the KD Nuggets blog
and it's from February 24 2017 through
May 27th 2019 now these are job postings
from indeed and these guys tabulated for
how many jobs these languages appeared
in the description now Python is in
first place and it's got somewhere
around double what are has sequel is in
a close second that's no surprise there
for me at all but they then go on to say
are increased massively from 2017 to
2019 but not near as much as Python jobs
increased so circling back to our
question of the day which one should you
learn R or Python and again from a
global perspective there is absolutely
not one right answer that answer is
tailored to you and to a certain extent
probably to your industry and to your
region you have to ask yourself are you
more of a statistics person more of a
programmer or neither the best possible
thing that you can do is really buckle
down and learn one of these languages
apply it get good at it develop
expertise and then later come back
and learn enough of the other one to be
dangerous there is a real risk that if
you try to learn too many things at once
you might end up failing at everything
but if over the long run you do buckle
down you get good at one you master it
you go back and learn the other one and
master that uh-huh
mark my words employers are going to
want to hire you and they're going to
want to pay you as my final
recommendation before learning either of
these two I would learn sequel you saw
that it appeared in almost as many job
descriptions specific to data science as
Python dead and there's really tons of
downstream benefits to having a good
fundamental understanding of databases
and multi relational data sets based on
these analyses there is certainly some
evidence that are is losing popularity
while Python is just going to the moon
and this could continue unless R comes
out with some new capabilities or some
new perks so just make of this
information what you will but the most
important thing is to learn one of these
and get good at it because I guarantee
you are is not going anywhere in the
next year not the next few years after
that there's tons of companies that
still use it and once you get good at
one of these you should hasten your
ability to get good at the other one
what do you guys think are you gonna be
using more R or more of Python in 2020
let me know in the comments thanks all
for watching this video until next time
richer on data